[Music]
in this year's german elections
the greens are playing with the big boys
it's been quite a campaign for the party
they spent months as number two in the
polls giving quite a scare to
traditional leading parties on the
center right and center left that seemed
to justify the bald step they took this
time around to put forward a green
candidate for chancellor something
they'd never done before
that candidate is analina baybach the
rules had to be changed to make room for
her in the tv debates until now there'd
only ever been two candidates
omens of success were there for those
who looked for them for a while it
seemed possible that bayabak could
succeed angela merkel as chancellor
and so beginning
[Music]
and a with shaft for deutschland
such an idea shows how far the greens
have come
some still think they bear traces of
their radical anti-establishment early
days
for others the greens are the fear bots
patai the party of bands a party that
wants to stop everyone eating meat and
driving combustion engine cars bourgeois
and urban and out of touch with real
life
but the party has moved away from its
anti-establishment radicalism and is
trying to reframe its nagging woke
reputation and although it all feels new
and the idea of a green chancellor is
fresh the greens have been here or near
here before
those radicals didn't look like a party
of government but their demands for
fundamental changes in german society
and politics found an audience
reinhard bhutikova has been a green
party member since the early 1980s he
became party leader in the early 2000s
and is now a member of the european
parliament
we were
an opposition party we were
we called ourselves an anti-partying
party we wanted to be completely
different
we wanted to bring a completely
different new agenda
to the national conversation
we uh
we were strilled and we were loud
it wasn't just their political clothing
that stood out in the traditional
setting
when joshua fisher became the first
green to be sworn in as state minister
he wore sneakers to the ceremony
a symbol of a new generation a new
movement taking its place in the
political arena
the states have been a success story for
the greens they've gradually built up
their voter base and are now part of the
government in 11 of germany's 16 states
and they didn't stop at state
governments for a party that's just four
decades old the greens have a lot of
experience under their belts they
consistently had mps in the federal
parliament
they've been there since 1983 when they
first took seats in the then west german
bundestag and 15 years later they joined
the federal government for the first
time as junior coalition partners to the
social
democrats joshua fischer swapped his
sneakers for some more formal shoes and
stepped into the prestigious role of
foreign minister
their time in government made the green
seem more like a serious political party
there were some victories the park green
government introduced the policy to
phase out nuclear power but they also
had to manage the realities of being in
charge including some difficult
decisions
perhaps the one that stirred up the most
conflict within the party was one that
challenged the deeply held pacifism of
many greens
germany decided with fisher as foreign
minister to support nato's 1999 bombing
of serbia during the kosovo war eugen
tritin was the green environment
minister at the time he was next to
fisher at the tumultuous meeting when
the party voted on the kosovo decision
this was a lesson i think for a lot of
greens also
it's complicated to cover
there are backlashes
but you can succeed even in such
complicated situations
when you go to war
that you seriously
all of us
including joshua didn't want it but we
failed to avoid it
being anti-war was a founding principle
of the party many members left feeling
their morals had been compromised
i think that was the moment when the
majority of the green party decided that
we would go down a
reformist
trajectory
we used to have two wings in the party
the the red so-called really wing
which was more or less the pragmatist
wing and and the so-called fully
fundamentalist wing
that's when
most of the leading fundamentalists
decided
they were no longer going to support
this project
[Music]
the greens served in two governments
they proved they could do it and in the
meantime it seemed like society was
catching up with their environmental
thinking
the overarching crisis is climate change
it's really happening and is starting to
hit at home
only this summer floods devastated
communities in central europe with
hundreds of people killed in western
germany
fires raged in the mediterranean after
weeks of scorching temperatures
and while the greens used to seem
eccentric for worrying about the
environment not everyone's doing it
people are demanding that even
mainstream products are more climate
friendly and industry is responding it's
easy to drive an electric car to sign up
for wind and solar generated electricity
and even to eat a meat-free burger
should you want to
this mainstreaming of green ideas and
the advance of the climate crisis means
that established parties campaign on
such issues too
the greens prime policy now belongs to
everyone but some suggest this doesn't
have to mean political disaster
and yet
not
um
while society at large has moved towards
the greens the greens have also taken
steps to win over the average voter
there's sort of a pull and push
mechanism going on between german
society and the german
green party
and
one could say that today the party is
a almost like a catch-all party
they've deliberately moved towards the
political center for example they now
embrace business as an ally in the fight
against climate change and they relax
their position on genetic engineering
and research
this process of softening and moving to
the center has been driven by the
party's current leadership and they
managed to bring the party with them
the greens elected robert habeck along
with analena bayabo as joint party
leaders in january 2018. they are
next generation
habig was in high school when fisher
became state minister in those sneakers
and baya book was in kindergarten she
was born the same year the party was
founded in 1980
they are focused and politically hungry
and alice is
but many particularly young people say
they haven't been bald enough in mapping
out those possibilities fridays for
future activists have attacked the
greens for not being strong enough on
climate protection
i think it's okay it's necessary
without a social movement like fridays
for future
we won't
bring anything through legislation
because we won't get a huge majority for
them
and on the other side without greens and
government these movements won't get
bring through anything
so this is a form of work share and part
of the workshop is that they criticize
us we have to do with that
it is a difficult position to be in they
need broad support to get enough votes
to gain office so they can do things but
they also risk contradicting their
entire founding principles if they move
too far to the center
the greens posed a significant challenge
to the two main parties on a national
level a remarkable feat for a young
party but their impressive surge at the
start of the campaign seemed to ebb as
election day got closer by early
september a green chancellor to replace
michael seemed unlikely this may have to
do with the party's lack of experience
remember they never put forward a
chancellor candidate before always
aiming to be part of government not the
lead coalition partner
and their chancellor candidate analina
bayabak is also inexperienced
she has been an mp in germany's federal
parliament for eight years but she's
never had any governing responsibility
at federal or state level and that made
her vulnerable to attack
not only that
allegations that baebook had embellished
her cv and plagiarized parts of her book
hit the party in the polls
most importantly it made people question
how competent the party was that this
could even happen
these mistakes disappointed many who
found the idea of a young green
chancellor an exciting one they'll
likely cost the party votes on september
26th
ultimately how babook and the party do
on election day will depend on whether
they can convince enough voters that the
sneakers and the nagging have really
gone and they're competent to govern